for decades they've stepped up when
health is really needed it's the Ronald
McDonald House it assists families who
are dealing with long hospital stays for
one reason or another but there's a long
waiting list for the Ronald McDonald
House Joshua peguero is with us live
this morning to talk about a new complex
the nonprofit is building to meet the
need Josh good morning
good morning John and Heather at 10 in
the morning there will be a
groundbreaking for this new complex so
it has about eight families and as you
mentioned during the intro John this
will cut down the waiting list for
families with sick children now this is
a rendering of the new Ronald McDonald
House at 10 in the morning there will be
a there will be several elected
officials local celebrities and as well
the CEO Allison McCarthy who joins me
here live so one of the things you
talked to us about is how Innovative
this new Ronald McDonald House is can
you explain it we were so excited to be
breaking ground finally after a year and
a half of planning on this beautiful new
project and what makes it a little bit
different is we're in a 13 000 square
foot facility it's three floors and all
of the amenities are common areas that
common formal living room a common
playroom we're in the big Raiders room
right now as you can see what makes this
facility different is that these are
eight individual patio homes each with
their own kitchens each with their own
laundry units a master bedroom a
children's bedroom yet in the middle
they all open out into this big Central
Courtyard where all of these common
amenities a playground barbecue grills a
park-like environment there so it's got
the best of both worlds but in the event
of a pandemic surge these families can
isolate and be safe as their own intact
family unit in their own patio homes
it's very Innovative now you serve about
200 families a year currently we have
families waking up but tell us a little
bit about some of the work that you all
do yeah so we are known as a temporary
home away from home and families who
need to travel to Las Vegas so that
they're little ones who are usually
critically ill or injured can get that
highly specialized medical need well
they're in the hospital we take care of
the moms and dads and the brothers and
sisters so that they can remain close to
that child's bedside because research
shows that children who have their loved
ones their family members their siblings
there to support them during the
recovery role they do so much better
Josh they heal faster they don't need as
much pain medication and they just cope
better family is medicine and that is
the mission here at the Ronald McDonald
House again the groundbreaking is at 10
in the morning and there will also be a
special announcement where they'll be
receiving the largest monetary donation
reporting live Joshua peguero eight news
now back to you in studio a wonderful
organization Josh thank you for that